en juin un homme observe par la fenêtre
sa voisine d'en face cela dure un peu
plus d'une heure cela s'appelle brève
histoire d'amour pour qui aime le
dépouillement de l'image et la
perversité des intentions c'est un très
beau film polonais signé krzysztof
kieslowski nicole cornu langlois noël
alexandre ça bien
un réalisateur polonais à sa fenêtre
que lui inspire paris j'ai dit une dame
dans une cabine téléphonique au kawa
elle pleurait amené move ioniques
mais n'ayez rien puisque je n'ai pas le
choix ou bien elle n'a pas eu cette
communication
alors qu'à gauche où elle pleurait vers
quelqu'un aujourd'hui story j'ai vu
plein d'histoires quand je veux mes
cheveux comme dans chhabiyé
et même si nous raconte une brève
histoire d'amour christophe casnos qui
crée un univers étrange dérangeant fait
de silence et de regards un jeune voyeur
timide une femme libre et cynique des
relations insolite est très forte dans
une ville austère dans laquelle je vis
et les gens qui m'entourent mouvement
centriste mais moi je ne peux pas mentir
et dire qu'ils sont gays nous sommes ils
ne le sont pas vincenzo culture du tacot
je ne tourne mais je ne pense pourtant
pas que le poids de la vie un certain
poids de la vie soit assise différent
ici et là bas d'autant que l'europe nous
avons rarement des raisons pour une
grande joie ouverte
le show par hugin mais je suis pourtant
à la recherche de quelque chose de clair
de lumineuses ce lumineuse c'est
peut-être la force d'une rencontre qui
fut oublier la grisaille la solitude des
villes à charte au bouche à oreille
ils faisaient jouer l'option du damier
avec maintenant
notre pote
un bon film lyrique malgré sa gravité
le sombre convient bien à cet auteur qui
doit tout de même parfois rêver au film
qu'il réaliserait avec plus de moyens et
plus de libertés